bonjour alex rivière merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur ce plateau pour
parler de ce mouvement qui va débuter à
14h grève massive des enseignants suivi
par les parents d'élèves on sait on
connaît les raisons mais dites nous
pourquoi une telle colère la jeunesse de
cette colère elle part n'a réellement
pour nous en met 2020 c'est à dire qu'au
moment où on annonce le premier
déconfinement nous a bien conscience que
la pandémie va pas s'arrêter avec enfin
à pas se dire tiens je m'arrête parce
que c'est la rentrée scolaire donc on a
tout fait pour préparer cette rentrée
nous n'avons jamais réussi à dresser
autre chose qu'une rentrée dite normale
en janvier en septembre 2020 et toutes
les rentrées qui ont succédé derrière se
sont succédé la même manière dire que
les en préparation oui la préparation
puis surtout refus de refus de se dire
on va oui on a un vrai problème en fait
on peut pas mettre les élèves les uns à
côté des autres comme ça au contact des
adultes sans que la pandémie flambent
mais je vous rappelle qu'on me disait
que l'école n'était pas contaminée
absolument fin il y avait une tout en un
discours qui était très compliquée à
mettre en oeuvre et parlant plutôt des
malades donc là on est au bout d'un
processus en définitive donc donc vous
qualifier là l action du gouvernement
manque de préparation
incompréhension de ce qui se passe dans
les classes comment est-ce que vous
jugez 7 cette impréparation en tout cas
et c'est quoique successifs dans les
protocoles à l'école
le lendemain si on voit la même chose
d'un côté voyez la présidente de région
et lycées en ile de france et puis
effectivement le prépare à la
préparation du gouvernement on les sent
très concentré sur la campagne
présidentielle et pas du tout sur la
scolarité des enfants donc nous on est
on est géré valérie pécresse par exemple
d'un câble de mettre un casier par
élèves dans chaque lycée de l'île de
france bon nous on n'arrive pas vraiment
à travailler avec elle depuis huit ans
sur ces choses très simples mais
jean-michel bancaire sa politique c'est
de ne surtout pas fermer des classes est
ce que vous pensez que c'est la bonne
stratégie mais c'est une très bonne
stratégie à condition de trouver des
moyens de donner un exemple concret une
école matin une école une petite école
un tout petit réfectoire pour faire
déjeuner les élèves juste à côté dans la
même école vous avez un gymnase pourquoi
est ce qu'on se dit pas tiens on met des
tables des chaises éphémère avec une
rotation mais tous que sa demande de des
gens en plus ça demande une organisation
et on sent pas du tout ce dialogue qui
se noue entre les collectivités
territoriales donc communes départements
régions pour préserver l'école enfin
c'est c'est compliqué on va en parler
avec une gueule blank qui qui est mère
de famille bonjour madame blanc que vous
avez deux enfants vous avez deux enfants
de quel âge et comment ça s'est passé
cette semaine avec vos enfants alors
j'en ai une la première elle est assise
en donc aller en primaire
du coup j'ai un petit garçon en mater
qui a trois ans donc petite section et
vous avait lieu vous avez dû faire des
tests pour vos enfants donc pas encore
d'accord les tests non l'été seulement
qu'à contacter ou quand il ya un k2o
vite
vérifié déjà dans la classe
et pour ma fille j'en n'ai pas encore
fait mon garçon non plus ils ont eu des
tests salivaires
il ya un peu près
c'était avant les vacances
donc les deux sont revenus négatifs
qu'est ce que vous pensez des nouvelles
mesures qui ont été imposées à l'école
par le ministre jean michel blanquer
pour être très honnête
un petit peu bordélique
parce que ça change tout le temps donc
on sait plus où on en est
voilà c'est ça le problème un alex
rivières c'est ce côté ça change tout le
temps les syndicats parlent même d'une
pagaille indescriptible vous êtes
d'accord avec ça ah oui mais c'est bon
que ça change tout le temps c'est le
résultat vraiment d'une impréparation da
manque de place dans dans les locaux de
comment est ce qu on répartit les élèves
et les adultes qui en ont la charge
enfin plus effectivement de toute la
partie ventilation qui est pas organiser
pourquoi est ce qu'on prend pas un
personnel par exemple
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'arrangement avec
les communes pour passer dans les
classes pour dire bon bah tiens on
ventile comme ci comme ça il n'y a pas
un plan ventilation cette question de la
ventilation dans l'une à ce qui doit
prendre en charge le coup parce que
c'est un coût supplémentaire évidemment
pour les classes le gouvernement nous
expliquait un budget de 20 millions moi
j'ai discuté avec
cinq élus à l'éducation en
seine-saint-denis en début de semaine
qu'ils me disent tous la même chose on
ne sait pas où ils sont les guichets et
quand on trouve les guichets pour
retrouver ces subventions nous n'avons
pas les ressources humaines nécessaires
à mobiliser pour remplir ces dossiers de
demande de subventions donc est ce qu'il
n'ya pas moyen que chacun s'arrange
entre eux pour que les choses puissent
s'arranger pour les élèves réellement
tout ça fait quand même 2 ans que cette
pandémie
existe un il était temps il est temps il
est temps d'agir à ce niveau là sur les
mesures de prévention les masques ffp2
pour les professeurs ça a été une piste
aussi voulait souhaité mais moi je
souhaite tout toute forme
d'améliorations vraiment bénéfique pour
les élèves enfin vous rendez compte on
parle de masques ffp2 deux ans après
début de la pandémie alors pour les
professeurs jco sont pas tous arrivés
c'est ça et qu'on sait qu'il nous fait
des masques transparent pour pour les
petites classes pour que les enfants
voient les labial enfin on marche un peu
sur la tête quand même inge blanc que ça
fait deux ans que cette pandémie existe
sur la planète les enfants qui sont
obligés de mettre des masques en cours
comment est-ce que vous jugez vous le
les restrictions qui sont imposées pour
les petits
alors pour les masquer il ya une chose
que je comprends pas c'est que sur la
cour on leur laisse pas un peu de
liberté
parce que bon on sait très bien que
quand ils vont sortir de l'école ils
vont l'enlever et ils seront toujours
avec les mêmes copains ou copines qui
sont sur le coup
donc ça je comprends pas déjà c'est
difficile à lire aux enfants
alors pour ma fille ça va parce qu'en
fait quand elle était déjà en maternelle
je lui ai déjà mis quelques fois le
masque quand on sortait
pour l'ajustement l'habitude et parce
que je savais que quand elle allait
arriver en cpl allez devoir le m
voilà et vous en tant que parent comment
est ce que vous vivez ces mesures
imposées à des tout petits enfants
mais difficile parce que du coup moi
j'ai vu une classe qui devaient rentrer
chez eux
les petits sont là mais qu'est ce qui se
passe pourquoi on rentre à la maison
donc du coup aller les enseignants il
disait à l'école c'est fini
or que sur la courbe il y avait encore
d'autres et classes y jouer donc les
petits soient là mais regardez il ya ne
peut pas aller copines sont en train de
jouer à l'école l'école n'est pas fini
pour humer pour vous aussi qu'est ce qui
se passe en fait les enfants ils sont un
peu perdus et ça avoir ça en étant par
an ça fait mal au coeur
alex rivières le ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer a dit
qu'on ne faisait pas grève contre un
virus qu'est ce que vous lui répondez
moi je pense qu'il faut pas qu'il fasse
la grève de l'humilité et même sa
démission je suis même pas sûr que ce
soit une bonne solution puisque je dire
puisqu'il se targue d'être le ministre
qui reste le plus longtemps en poste
qu'il aille jusqu'au bout afin fins et
je pense qu'ils sont ils sont à bout de
solutions et qui a un manque réel
d'humilité juste pour avoir un dialogue
et 6 et de sauver ce qu'on peut sauver
scolarité sur cette année déconnexion du
réel
oui on peut parler de ça oui qu'est ce
que vous lui demandez aujourd'hui à
cette mobilisation quelques et quelles
mesures vous souhaiteriez pour l'école
aujourd'hui qu'on se mette autour de la
table et qu'on se dise tiens comment
est-ce qu'on va préparer la rentrée
prochaine parce que là actuellement dans
tous les établissements de france sont
et dans tous les rectorats sont discutés
les moyens pour l'année prochaine dire
qu'est ce qu'on va donner vos la rentrée
de septembre absolument moi je pense
qu'il faut qu'on se concentre sur sur la
préparation de la rentrée de septembre
même si ce n'est plus mais ministre même
si ce n'est plus tout ça puisque c'est
maintenant que ça se fait et on moi
j'aurais bien qu'on ait une rentrée en
septembre soit pas chaotique et tout le
monde vous voyez vous entendez les
petits sont perdus enfin tout le monde
est dépassé par la situation aurait
enfin des petits mais c'est le cas aussi
des lycéens ou des des collégiens oui ça
se manifeste sous d'autres formes mais
on sait aussi pourquoi ça pourquoi ça va
pas chez les enfants ce moment il ya des
problèmes psychologiques liés à toutes
les mesures vous pensez chez les enfants
est ce que est ce que les professeurs
constatent des comportements qui diffère
à cause de ces mesures il ya une forte
augmentation des conseils de discipline
dans le second degré donc en collège et
en lycée et la cause du non respect des
mesures pour l'instant un certain nombre
de choses parce que cette situation
comme ça de cocotte-minute vous imaginez
bien ça crée une ambiance pas du tout
agréable dans les établissements donc
forcément quand n'est pas agréable se
passe plus de choses désagréables avec
des sanctions qui peuvent être plus
forte il ya un taux d'absentéisme aussi
lié à ce variant omicron dans les écoles
qui complique encore davantage la tâche
mais chacun chacun effectivement est
touché par la pandémie est malade
et tous approcher la journée des
remplaçants évidemment mais les
remplaçants ils commencent à les
embaucher maintenant qu'on est un petit
qu'ils ont embauché en milieu d'année
l'année dernière dire qu'ils font pas
les choses sérieusement il donne les
moyens mais à un moment donné c'est trop
tard fin quand années lancé géré quand
vous avez commencé commencer une recette
vous rajoutez pas des nouveaux
ingrédients en plein milieu sens en tout
perturbé est-ce que vous demander à être
consulté aussi est ce que c'est le cas
d'ailleurs quand les mesures sont prises
ils consultent de plus ou moins mais
toute façon il ya une écoute qui est
plus ou moins plus ou moins attentive
mais mais mais on a une divergence de
fond sur sur la distanciation nécessaire
entre tous les humains qui sont en
milieu scolaire inge blank dernière
question vous soutenez aujourd'hui les
les enseignants qui sont dans la rue
pour manifester
l'école on est de tout coeur avec eux
parce que c'est sûr que ils sont aussi
un petit peu en premier ligne
ils accueillent nos enfants toute la
journée pendant la pandémie n'est pas
très facile pour eux non plus
avec le protocole qui change tout le
temps
du coup bas même eu des fois ils sont un
petit peu perdu et ça plus quoi faire
comme alix rivières le disait aussi il
ya des sanctions a donné aux enfants
qui ne suit pas le protocole mais ça
vous trouvez que ça rectifié à la police
en fait vous trouvez que c'est justifié
de d'imposer des sanctions aux enfants
qui ne suivraient pas les protocoles
j'ai envie de vous dire comment voulez
vous les faire comprendre autrement
merci
[Musique]
c'est comme ça merci beaucoup inge blank
merci merci beaucoup pour votre
témoignage en tout cas en direct dans la
matinale de rtl france merci à vous
merci à vous merci à vous également alex
rivière d'être venu sur ce plateau vous
serez à la manifestation cet après midi
à paris à partir de 14h merci beaucoup
merci à vous